this podcast and every other podcast I
make is brought to you by our supporters
on patreon who are the reason that these
somewhat Niche podcasts are able to
exist supporters on patreon get ad-free
versions of all podcasts now including
playwatch listen plus extra content
outtakes even longer episodes of
playwatch listen have existed on patreon
and for a recent update because this
previously wasn't happening patreon will
now also receive all video versions of
playwatch listen without YouTube ads so
check it out if you want to support the
show our current goal is to be able to
fund hopefully monthly playwatch listen
animations but we have grander plans
beyond that too of course you don't need
to do any of this it's just a nice way
to support the show if you enjoy it now
to the show alright hi Mike how you
doing
I'm good it's been a while when was the
last time I actually saw you like what
happened on the show for like three
weeks I don't think
um turns out uh video game launch hell
of a thing it's a bit busy
yeah it was really cool it was a really
cool experience so we had
um a countdown day that I was a day that
I happened to be in the office anyway
and so there were just people all over
the place
um with a TV screens that were like this
many hours until
launched they actually put the countdown
up on the screen so it was there all day
um and then you know had like just a
bunch of beers and white clothes and
food and stuff in the office that night
while everyone was waiting for the
countdown which was really cool it was
very cool to meet so many people that I
work with in person for the first time
um including and this was a really cool
thing I had maybe like
I'm gonna say 10 people at the studio
come up to me either at the the
countdown night or the launch party
and say that playwatch listen inspired
them to get a job and now they work at
Santa Monica Studio
[ __ ] thing and I was like and we work
together that's crazy
um yeah it happened it happened tons of
people just being like you know I was
gonna give up and then the way you guys
talk about it and like the suggestion to
go to GDC I just did all that stuff and
now I work here and I was like all right
well I'm glad we're not totally full of
[ __ ] it's so sweet I'm always amazed by
that because I've I've hit the age now
where I meet people in the street in
Industry who are like I loved your games
when I was a kid
and now that's the one that's like
to have that one day though because like
people that I work with so often in
meetings go like oh well what I was
working on Far Cry 2 and I go what yeah
and it happens so often that I'm like I
get to be that for somebody one day I
get to be like when I was working on
this thing like that's cool oh I feel
like I freak out all the time but yeah
so that was really cool and then we had
just an actual rap party the day after
which was at um
I think it's called The Coliseum in L.A
it's where fortnite usually does their
E3 parties so I used to at least which
is a very big cool thing it's definitely
uh more money than any other company
I've ever worked for because the IGN
holiday parties were usually at like
some tiny bar and the rooster teeth
holiday parties were at the office and
something rented out like the Olympic
Coliseum in La uh amazing food
um yeah it was it was
it was just a really cool experience
very celebratory and obviously people
seem to really like the game so
yeah that's great it reviewed
phenomenally right I'll be honest I
still need to go back and play the last
one so I'll get it seriously 2018. I I
did the thing I often do I can't
remember what it was it must have been
that there was like an event or a
milestone I played like the first five
six hours had a really good time and
then just got busy for a month and never
came back to which happens to me all the
time April which is like kind of a weird
that might have been there maybe it was
the E3 kind uh I got caught up in like I
think maybe we were was it during what
year was that 2018.
potentially I know something there was
basically something that ate up my time
I can't remember I also have this like
weird thing of the E3 where you were
doing Wick because I was supposed to go
see it but couldn't and I remember being
very upset about that because I got an
email about it I was supposed to go see
it this is before we had this show I
remember like that was there was one of
two games that I couldn't see that I
really wanted to see and I feel like
that being 2018 makes sense to me I
think that was either 2019. the best one
that the E3 one was fun because we had a
room just wrapped in gold the the
funniest thing and I might have even if
you had come along I might have made you
do the exact same thing was was Greg
showed up Greg Miller to look at it and
it was just it was like two days into E3
obviously knackered back-to-back
meetings and both of us we were just
chatting I think he was chatting about
we were trying just about General [ __ ]
and starting to get onto the like and
hit weird hits I could just tell he
wasn't that super like interested or
he's tired or something just like Hey
we're friends
do you want to just close the door to
this room and tell the people outside
that I was reviewing I was showing you
this game for half an hour and you'll
just lie on the floor and talk [ __ ] to
each other so me and Craig just hug out
in that in that room pretending to be
demoing a game uh just because we both
by that point were so knackered we're
like I know that you were a nighttime
appointment for me and there was there
was a reason I couldn't make it I think
it was like a demo on the show floor or
something went long let's go yeah
um and you were at the Fig or you were
in a hotel right
we were a hotel yeah just around the
corner so it was it was difficult enough
to get to that I think you I don't think
you were the only one who couldn't do it
I think there were a couple of dropouts
yeah just like literally like Logistics
like CES is a nightmare of a show that I
hope I never have to work again the last
time I went there I just DJ the party
which was great but working CES as a
journalist was hell because it's so hard
to get anywhere in Vegas in general and
when people have meetings in different
hotels and you know you try and you get
in the lobby or whatever and you're
trying to find somebody's room or you're
trying to get from one hotel to the next
hotel just connecting two hotels
together and everything's trying to keep
you in a casino it's yeah
it's actively working against you it's
so important I've never done CEOs the
only Vegas things I go to a dice but
it's much smaller yeah it's
great but even then usually like dice
last year I just ran into Austin I was
like where the [ __ ] do I go to get my
badge should he had to walk me there
um but CES also has the problem of there
being so much Tech in a small space or
relatively small compared to the amount
of tech that your phone also just won't
work so again being a journalist and
trying to find people or contact people
or like just meet somebody on a show
floor just so difficult like it's it is
a very cool oh I just got a notification
for PC game pass I have one free month
of PC game pass and have PC game
tweeting thank you Xbox so exciting
audio is going to show up so it's just
letting everyone know
um but yeah definitely not my favorite
show to work but I had this um
thinking the other day like again you
know but what I do now is awesome and
it's what I've wanted to do for a really
long time and I wouldn't trade it but I
was just looking through old photos and
being like man
the way that E3 was even five years ago
was [ __ ] awesome and uh it's sad that
that probably won't exist now obviously
e3s Now read Pop
um but even then like my job would never
work the same way like I won't just go
to E3 and walk to show floor ever again
like it's very it's very weird the
passage of time if you're ever there
again you're going to be locked in one
room yeah for four days answering the
same questions over and over again yeah
yeah I always feel bad a big smile on
your face that's such an interesting
question thank you so much for asking it
no they're lying when they say that they
get that all the time oh damn it I knew
it
I actually had I had that it's like I
can't remember what it was I think it
was when I was doing John Wick promo and
like there was someone who asked a
question that genuinely was really
interesting and genuinely was the first
time with us I remember like I said it
and I was like oh but actually like for
real this time like I know we always say
that to you but that's actually like it
was good actually a good moment like I'm
actually not bullshitting around animals
yeah I love that no I'm excited to see
where E3 goes but it's definitely like
just a big a big shift and a big change
and I also had this thing where I was
just looking through old photos again I
don't even know why I was doing it I
think I was I was deleting stuff and um
seeing all these photos from when I
worked in an office
kind of hit me in a way I'm very
introverted and I liked my own time a
lot and working in an office was not
good for me because I'm always so tired
I'd get home and I'd sleep at 7 pm and
then wake up the next day at night and
go to work like it just wasn't a great
way to live
um and that's not even exaggeration the
amount of goddamn sleep that I need and
so I'm much better off not working in an
office but still seeing pictures of like
how social I was made me like damn like
I often go a week without talking to
anybody it's like just a couple it's
also about getting older as well like
that's definitely like like I look back
at pictures of like me and my Twitter
like when I'm when I was in my 20s moved
to London and just like was out every
night hanging out with people like it's
just it's yeah it never changes as you
go I mean I think I did that when I was
like 16 I was going to nightclubs using
my sister's ID so I got that out of my
system real early I burned out on
nightclubs before I was legally allowed
to go to them definitely saves I think I
was like 19 done I don't need any more
about them good yeah hard pass on that
which is also
um time what is it um but yeah so I'm
assuming that you have not played
Ragnarok I would have loved to have
spoken to you guys about it but
no I will I will I need to just find the
time I over Christmas I I genuinely need
to catch up because I just not played
with um
yeah had the time to play games at all
do you play immortality I think that you
and Austin might have spoken about it
immortality I did play did you like it
the only reason I [ __ ] loved it
absolutely brilliant I think it's his
best
um the um the did you not like it no and
I I want to know where it'll work for
you let's talk this is the god this is
this is the podcast
most people don't know of but you should
we I mean we talk about his games on the
show all the time and we're gonna spoil
everything yeah
um well I haven't played it or finished
it so um
well I've technically I've seen the
ending which is something that at some
point I need to talk to Sam about
because I always see the ending in his
games before I'm supposed to it's
probably common with this one
what are we talking about right now
immortality what is this a video game at
least this year
um immortality it's uh the premise of it
is you are basically given
um a bunch of reels of footage from
three movies and like Associated
material behind the scenes Talk Show
interviews stuff like that yeah yeah
um and you are basically
and this I can see why this maybe I'm
just I'm starting to preempt what I
think you might not like about it but it
definitely kind of relies on your own
interest in kind of clicking through
those and kind of discovering all of
this stuff and then the the main
mechanic of the game is scrubbing around
well sorry the main mechanic of the game
because the sambolo game is what's going
on in your brain in terms of constant
like recontextualization of what you've
seen and kind of piecing this together
but the actual like the interaction the
mechanic is
um it's that thing that I can never
remember the name of which is about the
juxtaposition of two shots but it's
basically you can find moments of like
an object or item in the scene and you
tap on it and then that opens up a new
clip for you and you're kind of so
you're kind of basically like unlocking
essentially just all of these sequences
um and eventually you get both you know
uh uh best bits uh version of a film and
then a bunch of behind the scenes
materials and you're kind of uncovering
I guess the central question of the of
the of the story is you know why is why
did this actress stop being and stuff
that's like the thing you're trying to
discover and then there's
then it becomes very horary in a way
that I wasn't expecting and really
freaked me out oh
well someone should have told me that
oh we are going to have to have layers
of spoiler conversation on this call
because there's a there's a layer that I
think a lot of people haven't seen of
this game which is substantial
did you have a play inscription after we
spoke about it I did I never got past
I've not got past like the first game
basically
you don't want to talk too much about
the other [ __ ] that's in it because
finding out that that stuff is there is
the coolest part
that's part of the thing with
immortality but I genuinely think some
people just haven't spotted it because
of and it's I think there's a specific
controller reason basically you have to
do something with the control if I'm if
I we talking or I'm trying to work
because I don't know what you're saying
okay so there's like there's a
controller there's an input method so
basically you're you're using kind of
these weird controls to kind of move
back and forth through footage and
there's a quirk to that interaction that
reveals like an extra layer to the whole
thing which made it so that I couldn't
play the game at night anymore like
that's how scary it becomes if you find
that element okay
absolutely because I've already tried to
play it three times and it wasn't into
it and now I'm like
it gets scary okay so here's my name is
scary to me because I'm very very easy
to scare okay absolutely okay well I am
too but I really enjoy it in video games
um my issue with it versus his other
games which I like very much and I feel
like I always say his I should it's a
team of people it's always me that's
true unfortunately discrediting
everybody their games
um
is that I didn't actually feel like I
was solving uh uncovering a mystery I
felt like I was randomly clicking at
[ __ ] and then seeing what would show up
and I didn't feel that way about the
other games so like I felt like you know
her story I'm digging into something and
I feel like I have a direction for what
I'm choosing whereas with immortality oh
the Cup's clickable let's click on the
cup oh and you've seen oh the hair let's
click that but it wasn't there was no
driving force for me to do that other
than looking at imagery which I can do
anywhere
um so I think that's what it was is that
I didn't feel like I was
um
as involved
I don't think that's a fair criticism I
certainly that was my like my first hour
with it I remember like thinking like is
this it like because it does the the the
with her story there's obviously like
the finding of keywords you really that
feels the most investigative of all this
but telling lies as well just the kind
of the way the the juxtapositions of the
two halves of the conversations and
you're kind of holding it and putting it
together yeah yeah but you still get
very invested in those conversations
yeah you get yeah yeah it draws you in
whereas I think with this one it kind of
drops you with some clips that aren't
particularly interesting and and the
thing that's interesting about it
is kind of hidden in a way that the
first time you discover it is shocking
and surprising and scary and interesting
but if you've not gotten to that point
yet and it's it's that classic thing
it's like when someone recommends a TV
show to you where they're like oh it
gets so good and seriously Fantasy 15 or
whatever I think it's 13-2 and they're
like you just have to get through the
first 30 hours and then the game gets
good yeah so I'm always I'm always kind
of uncomfortable giving those kind of
recommendations but it's good to know
though because when I saw everybody
like no and again even the the fact that
it seems a lot more passive than their
previous games it doesn't feel like I'm
not even trying to criticize it it feels
more of a press no the passivity doesn't
change the passivity is still present
it's just it's just a
recontextualization and a
um a layering of narrative that's
interesting the the kind of that that
kind of sense you've got of like I don't
really feel like I'm finding anything
out there's or the mystery is not
intriguing when you start the game
I didn't feel like I was actively
uncovering the mystery whereas the other
two I don't know if they do they have
more than two games I've only played
telling lies in her story
those are the only two I've played okay
yeah maybe there's probably one there's
I mean obviously um Sam directed a uh
Silent Hill game before that didn't he
um
yes
whichever one that was uh because that
was when I met him
he [ __ ] they chipped out and he was um
he was just halfway through her I
remember this is one of my the funniest
thing about being like an indie Dev in
the UK because it's such a small country
is like you you meet everyone basically
and I remember me and him I think we
both like talked to a student thing or
something yeah you just meet everybody
at a school so it's Silent Hill Origins
and Silent Hill shattered Memories both
of them that's right um yeah they're the
two British directed ones
I remember meeting him in this bar and
chatting to him and him basically
telling me what her story was and I
remember and I've told him this since
like I remember just being like
I was gonna play in the FMV game with
like a Google search bar what is he
talking about like just I remember in
the moment just being very much like
that's that doesn't sound like I mean
they're not they had broadly played
they're just extremely beloved by the
people who do play her story was big was
it like that did some you I think her
story is like in the millions yeah wow I
don't know about the other ones but I
know I think her story was like across
all of its platforms and it was
obviously on mobile oh true it was on
mobile yeah then being on I think
immortality is on Game Pass I believe it
is I played on a steam but yeah
um but they're definitely unique games
and I'm very glad they exist because
they really do like you're right and I
never thought about it that way before
that they rely on your own brain is a
mechanic oh a lot um did you play
oberden
yeah great yeah I I'd leave the show
immediately if I'd not play that oh yeah
I would have been upset if you
specifically had not played Overton but
same thing
down right now and Carrie me and Carrie
like sat down like and and as is often
the case with me and Carrie all right
yeah I played it and we played it four
hours on that first night taking notes
and then the next morning woke up it's
like we have to go and finish over a day
then played it for another six hours or
whatever it was so yeah it's a great
game yeah
um but I feel like it's it's definitely
a thing with games like that even though
obraden is I guess not that dissimilar
in a weird way
and yeah I do think that that mechanic
is a thing and I think that maybe that
was the absence of appeal for me uh with
immortality was that I didn't actually
feel like I was really thinking very
much I was just watching and again I
don't think I've been trying to
I'm trying to relay a criticism I think
I'm relaying a preference
I don't think that I think it's a bad
thing I just think I don't enjoy it as
much
I think as well I think the thing with
immortality is I think and and I I I
like it to an extent is it's not making
you a detective I think immortality more
than any of the the previous stuff is
it's you and it's very much kind of
saying to you here's some video check it
out yeah and yes there is a certain
point where something happens and you're
like
is is the game
buggy or evil or like you're like
there's like genuinely like a mystery it
happens and that's what kind of Gets You
Through is it
something that people could find at a
different time like is it just like one
of the clips triggers it
you can watch all these clips out of
order and what you're trying to do is
piece them together every time one right
but you would watch them all at
completely out of order different to
everybody else depending on which mug
you clicked on and which thing you
clicked on from there it's like just a
big web it's a layer the answer is it's
a layer so it's it's essentially it's
always it's something that's present in
the game and everyone who's played it
will know exactly what I'm talking about
it's like if you played Mario and they
didn't tell you there was a jump button
and you were like this seems like a
pretty boring kind of running across the
screen and then you realize there's a
jump button it re-contextualizes it's
it's kind of a weirdly Metroid almost
like a one layer of Metroid of like you
you gain this knowledge that this thing
is in the game and it you PL you start
playing it differently but it's still
not like it's not it doesn't add depth
they're just basically
um expands I can give you I can give you
a clue after we finish recording that
we'll kind of steer you very quickly
towards finding this thing out because
I've tried it three times three times
it's like I really don't tell you a
thing that will get you onto this track
within like 10 minutes
yeah it was one that um because my dad
likes watching video games so when he
was in town I mean my whole family has I
think my mom watched me finish Fable 2
and have this really cool moment once
where my my stepdad is exactly 50 years
older than me too the day we're both
born on August 24th
and
he was watching me play Wolfenstein and
I didn't know I didn't have any contacts
with him ever playing video games and he
was like is this Wolfenstein and I was
like the [ __ ]
Stein and he was like I play Wolfenstein
when I was a kid and I was like oh my
God God that does make sense that you
want to play Wolfenstein but I have very
good memories of my family watching me
play video games and I so I was like oh
this could be a cool one for Dad he'd
probably like his other game so let's
try immortality and I feel like the
interest disappeared so fast from him
and then I was like well I'm not gonna
make you keep watching I think you're
not interested I don't know I don't want
to lose the threat of you enjoying
watching video games and then um tried
to Play It Again by myself and couldn't
tried it again after seeing how much
everyone else loved it just it's also
honestly not a game to play with your
dad in the room past a certain point
like it goes into some places that might
be awkward yeah yeah I I I'll try I'll
try it again because it's like like I
said my backlog this year is so bad um
did you have you played pentiment at all
I'm gonna assume you're gonna say no
based on the time no but I've you you've
raved about so much it's definitely on
the list very good you were very
excitable did you have a good poop
he said he wouldn't go in there give it
10 minutes
um yeah so pentiment's like a similar
one of just uh a game that I would
consider to be very dense
uh in that
you you kind of have to play it all at
once and I I feel like immortality is
probably pretty similar in that I think
if you tried to space pentimen out over
the course of six months you'd be
confused because you really do need to
know who all these towns people are and
one of these characters are up to and
oh it's snowing
well that's a lot of snow I'm in
Vancouver that's very pretty
um and yeah I feel like immortality is
the same I don't know how long it is but
I imagine if you stop playing it it's
probably not going to work out great
same as over 10 right it's not a game
that you want to watch yeah I'd say
they're both but they're they're binge
they reward a binge so how long how
long's pentiment then is that like a day
okay no uh 15.
15 hours yeah one review said they
finished it in 13 and notably that was
the most negative review that I saw
and I was like you finished this game in
13 hours
um but I get why you didn't love it
because that you got to be spamming
through dialogue to finish that game in
13 hours I would say it's 15. is it
maybe is it another couple's thing is it
like Overton would it be one that maybe
we could play together do you think or
is it more yeah no I think you could
actually once you get to act two because
it's a murder mystery right like the
stuff that I think is fun is like a
couple's game or I've played more games
like like uh I played the whole of oxen
free with an X and that was a really fun
time anything that's a mystery is fun
right uh yeah because that's that's fun
for the second person who's not holding
the play yeah those games where there's
a little bit of something yeah because
her story we played similarly like yeah
you could give it a try but yeah I think
it would work because it's also a thing
that I really like about pentiment is
you're trying to
figure out who committed uh the the
murder and there's actually
um I was just talking to Josh Sawyer
about it and there's no canonical answer
you choose
and whoever you choose as the murderer
gets put to death
but at no point will you ever be told if
you are right or wrong and I think that
yeah it's very medieval as well very
medieval oh this guy I guess kill him
whatever like it's and I think that's
really really cool
um and I I actually kind of want to go
through and like watch other people's
playthroughs and see who they chose and
what their reasoning is because I think
it would be a really fun discussion game
and I mean they're just so much fun I
actually um
I just ordered a PS5 to home in
Australia that's supposed to arrive
today which is shocking it said it was
going to take a month and then I guess
they came back in stock
um because my plan is to
show I might even return it when I'm
done to show each family member uh God
of War Ragnarok because none of them
have a PS5 so I was going to play it for
my mom and then play it for my stepdad
and I'll play for my dad and then my
sister as well and maybe even my grandma
to be like hey here's what this is like
my sister can can play video games my
mom can she plays games but has a lot of
trouble with Jewel sticks or whatever so
I thought that I might go home and do
that I might even record it just to see
what they think especially because the
opening hour is very emotional in a way
that I was actually worried about you
know when I first played the opening
hour I don't know two years ago I was
really worried that um it starts as too
much of a downer and people wouldn't
like it would be like this isn't God of
War uh but it is just people all over
the Internet crying in a good way so I
was like okay crisis averted everybody
likes it we'll take it I think I think
well I think I spent with all the Sony
first party stuff like I feel like it's
I think
Sony's taken the audience with them like
Sony's kept playing if there's a they've
retained to that audience so the
audience is like mature and interested
in those kind of stories yeah in a way
that is I guess you can only really do
when you have like Sony has been just
like looking after that generation of
Gamers all the way through it's
definitely an interesting thing with
Xbox Xbox has done similar things yeah
true slightly later yeah it's a very
interesting thing with um God of War
specifically is that I feel like it
literally has aged with the audience
yeah like a dad game right it's like the
logic is the people who were playing
this when they were teenagers uh well
it's my it's my age group it's like it's
like I think the first god of war came
out when I was just a bit too young to
play it but it had like Gore and boobs
so like teenager
and I think I was like eight
yeah so I was I would have been a how
yeah I would have been a teenager then
so maybe I was old enough to play it I
remember it being like one where I was
like on the cusp of
God of War One release date it was
really funny the other day I was talking
about how old I was when that came out
with um
one of our employees I'm not sure if our
title is public but uh she was like are
you serious because she had marked it
we've had a lot of employees who worked
there for a really really long time the
first one is 2005.
2005 allegedly
so I would have been I've been 20. I
remember I that's weird I remember being
much younger when that came out yeah I
guess it shows how mature I was at 20.
fair enough
you're a child a mere 20 years old
that's weird yeah in my head I've
totally put it into that
yeah but it's not there well that's it I
played three when it came out oh it was
a late stage so that's the classic
example then of like a very late PS2
game if that it was that thing where you
used to I don't know if it's as common
now just because the consoles kind of
blur together a bit more
um but like with the the end of the
ps2's lifespan like amazing because the
developers all knew how to make use of
the the hardware so all of those last
PS2 games similar with PS3 I mean um
that came out on the PS3 is so nuts when
you look at it compared to the launch
titles you're like Jesus Christ it's
crazy consoles used to be much harder to
make games for so it took years to learn
how to do it
the consoles are the switch is kind of
tough one Nintendo Hardware is a little
bit tough or has that changed now too
well it's tough if you're doing with
switch I mean I mean nowadays at my
level you're using
or unreal so the switch is just a layer
of that but yeah no it's this the switch
is obviously like much lower specs than
the other devices with p with
PlayStation 5 and the Xbox they're
basically PCS so from an architectural
point of view it's much more
straightforward whereas I remember
working like the first consoles I was
working on were like I worked on a PS2
game like one of my first jobs in
industry was PS2 and um and they're like
that Hardware was it was it made no
sense to anyone it was yeah it was all
it was especially Western developers
because a lot of the documentation and
even the code was like in Japanese like
it was a complete no way wow culturally
weird thing and it was it was fine like
I I say the code was in Japanese
everyone's screaming at the screen the
code wasn't in Japanese but a lot of the
kind of the terms and Technologies were
kind of yeah were kind of separated from
a western developer so yeah it was
nowadays things are a lot more
straightforward but yeah it still takes
time to learn the quirks of stuff and
we're always like we're always profiling
um you know consoles I'm just working
out what we've announced not announced
for various reasons um when you're when
you're working on Console stuff you are
always kind of profiling working out
like oh where are we where are where our
bottlenecks where are things working not
working and yeah I guess it gets yeah
and the
the uh
manufacturer side
um the engineering side can get better
at helping you
um yeah I was having an issue with the
dev kit like just a setup thing and it
was complicated and I needed a bunch of
help and then I happened to CC uh one of
our producers Carol Chung whom I love
um on an email thread and she previously
worked with PlayStation Hardware
engineering and the way that Carol
immediately was like right now we'll
just do this and I was like
I really should have thought to just ask
Carol first but I was like well I don't
want to bug her that's no she didn't
shouldn't have to worry about this and
then immediately she was like this will
work and it did and I was like [ __ ] like
of course that wouldn't work yeah she's
outside of industry and people in
Industry a lot of time forget that like
Tech is 90 of what you mean when you say
Tech it's just knowledge people in the
office have yeah and if you just go and
ask them you can find it out it's it's
what makes it's one of the many things
that makes the current Twitter situation
interesting is like by firing those
stuff they will have lost
information that is required to run that
website date you know not everything
you're talking about username
it just gives me an error every time
everyone's like there's less bugs than
ever your line is
no but you're absolutely right losing
people's knowledge is like one of the
worst things about people leaving in
general
um oh yeah like wait I mean I think
that's applied to every company I've
worked for but it feel like it hits
especially hard and Dev uh where I've
lost somebody's knowledge and if they
can't pass it on to the next person
that's just gone like it's it's
terrifying very intimidating and
likewise the flip of that which is nice
which is when you have people join like
we've we've done I was talking about
this with someone earlier because in the
last year we've gone from I want to say
five or six members of staff to 20 and
like what happens when you bring in that
many people and from like cool places
and with lots of experience in previous
games under their belt like it's it is
it is like it feels like our Tech got
upgraded because now we just have all
these clever people in the room who know
how to use this stuff and how to do
great stuff with it and I feel like you
can also find out what's wrong with your
system like um we had somebody join my
team and be like hey it's been most of
the year yeah if somebody joining my
team and be like hey what this it was
like oh yeah but because everyone else
on the team has been looking at the same
thing
we don't think to ask questions because
it's just that bubble and you need
somebody else to join to be like what
about this he's like oh [ __ ] yeah you're
right and I think that's like totally a
thing with with tech in general too is
they're going to be like Mike um this
sucks did you know that this sucks yeah
do you know this system literally obtuse
I've had two calls today that I've been
dealing with that exact problem in
different shapes they were both about
your personality so those were both like
directly complaining about me yeah so
that is the I do suck I do suck and it's
good but it's good to have people around
me who let me know that yeah but no it's
it's but the but all jokes inside like
the the institutional stuff is just as
important like the stuff we've learned
from just bringing in people who've
worked in other companies who we've
we've brought in people from AAA and
other ND Studios and stuff like that and
the amount of just like hey why are you
not doing this like this as a company
and just going oh I don't have a good
answer to that question that's a really
obviously better way of doing this you
know and it's just there's been so much
of that kind of the company's just
completely shifted in how we do almost
everything because we've got all these
talented new people coming in who who
know better and it's just been yeah it's
been amazing benefit of having
exhausting I bet yeah you're having a
great time is it a Pepsi kind of day
today Mike what kind of day is it I
don't even see a beverage well it is I
am drinking a Pepsi but no it's it's
been you know it's been a busy day today
I've had lots of calls today was one of
those back-to-back calls kind of days is
that uh like a big part of your job at
this point now you're effectively quote
unquote managing more people are you
stuck in one of those positions where
you are less creative and are more
meetings orientated that's my least
favorite part of my job is the amount of
time I have spending meetings
I'm very lucky and that my me I have I
have some really good people around me
who remove a lot of the meetings that
are not creative so most of my meetings
are created
so I have a lot of yeah I've got like
you know my business partner who does
all the kind of Biz Dev and day-to-day
business stuff I've got an office
manager I've got a producer like I've
got people around me who can kind of
carry that version
too like I've heard horror stories on
any Studios where the director slash
owner felt that they had to be involved
in everything because they didn't trust
other people to do that I'm like that
sometimes
I'm not gonna I'm not I'm not gonna if I
if I if I pretend otherwise I'll be
lying but no I think yeah but that's
been the that's been the I think I've
said this on the show before that's been
my process over the last 10 years it's
just going from dude who did everything
to like evolve into dude who does my
thing quite well but everyone else will
do much better with everyone that's
probably also learning what you're good
at and then just being like let me just
do this thing a lot yeah because yeah no
so it's been good I can't even imagine
but you know congrats again for for uh
growing a team and you know Tron it's
been it's it's been good and tron's been
good it's it's like it's you know it's a
shift but it's been really fun and and
yeah what we're what we're able to be
doing and the the toys we're going to
play with oh yeah yeah it's just been
great I'm torn between uh two questions
that I want to ask you so I'm just going
to go with the first one because I think
it'll be a quick one and the second
one's a question I've wanted to ask you
specifically for ages I'm like well this
is a mic episode let's go first one just
related to our previous conversation do
you have a game of the year this year
what would your 2022 Game of the Year be
based on uh your limited time to play
videos which again I feel the same
[ __ ] way this year it sucks
you're allowed to say immortality if you
want it might be immortality that's what
I'm thinking I'm thinking I'm trying
it's it's it you know when you're doing
your game of the game of the year and
you're like what knocks the obvious
answer off the top spot I think it might
be immortality even though I would be
the first to say I I think honestly I
think Sam would agree it's mechanically
it's not the most interesting mechanic
I've played this year but I would say
just from like a a story level and a
surprise level that's probably I don't
think like the winner it's a thing that
gets that was very difficult at uh when
I was impressed um even before ignac to
do some of this stuff of
trying to quantify what best means
like I have I think portal one is the
best game ever made some days and then
the next day I think it's portal 2. and
the reason that I make those arguments
with myself is because well Portal 2
only exists because Portal 1 exists but
then Portal 2 has a better story by a
mile yeah but then I like the the um
sort of reduced very typical maybe your
decimal review score of both games
it's a weird thing of trying to quantify
like when you are someone that game of
the year I can give you what I think the
best game of the year is and then my
favorite game of the year they aren't
necessarily the same thing and I think
like that's it's an annoying thing to
have to do to yourself but you do have
to do it like it's hard not to
um yeah I think for me it's the one that
I think has had the most impact on my
brain and I think I'd say mortality is
the that's the one that scared the [ __ ]
out of me and that I was thinking about
while not playing it that's a big one
for me it's like am I walking around my
life with this game still existing in
the back of my head mine are Elden ring
and I see you because I can't say go to
a Ragnarok it doesn't count and I also
just like don't look at it as a video
game um yeah be Elden ring and sifu and
I actually think sifu I wins for me
weirdly um I think Elden ring had like a
very big impact on me and I was so
obsessed with it and I do think it's
like
one of those
like it's a breath of the wild
um in that it just inspires so much awe
because of the sense of Discovery and I
think that's a really beautiful thing
about video games like even reading a
good book can be kind of similar feeling
but I don't feel like I get that a lot
from other entertainment mediums where
the appeal of Eldon ring is in walking
around and and turning a corner and
seeing something that you had no
expectation would be there I remember
like the first time that I was playing
it there's one point on the map or at
least I had a group of friends that were
doing this in like a Twitter DM threat
where I'd just be like have you seen
this and I would just have a screenshot
of the map and draw a little X but I
would never spoil what it was because I
was so often just walking into something
and being like holy [ __ ] just the way
that it looks the way that it moves like
that animation is so on point for that
game it's the the sense of discovery
that I wish more games would tap into
that I think Elder ring just absolutely
Nails in a way that just makes it like
so wondrous
um again same as breath of the wild for
me being like have you [ __ ] been here
and seen what this thing is so cool
otherwise it's sifu um which
I think it's even related like my
favorite from soft game is still Sakura
and that's because it's a rhythm game
sifu is effectively a rhythm game
um it's really stylish I love the the
sound design
and uh
just something about like mastering
those levels and going have you played
sifu
I've not I've watched a lot of footage
of it okay so you're probably familiar
with it conceptually where like At first
I was like okay you go through a level
and you fight people
got it fine but that's not it at all
it's going through a level and figuring
out how to approach the level until you
can get through the level without dying
and the fact that like first level I
think the first time I played it I
didn't even get to the end and then the
second time I'm playing through it
repeatedly just to grind effectively
though to like change my XP and I can do
that without dying ever I just [ __ ]
loved it like really really enjoyed it
um so those two would be
my picks but I think there was actually
a lot of really good games this year
especially in the Indie space or India
adjacent like I consider like pentaments
not indie but it has that kind of feel
to it especially when it's such a small
it was amazing in an indie adjacent way
little Skunk Works yeah same as uh maybe
grounded was the 13. in any case both of
those games which I love I love obsidian
the level with the stuff they're doing
right now they're one of my favorite
Studios right now is um
both of those games uh Indie adjacent in
the game pass game so I guess grounded
was screen light before game pass but
they're really small teams within a big
AAA team who's obviously working on uh
out of Worlds 2 and a vowed would be
their their big blockbustry ones so it's
just like like culture the lamb I'm
trying to think of like all the all the
just told alarm was excellent [ __ ]
all right boys so my second question
we had spoken on an episode before and
Monkey Island actually did this about
um the concept of
having
different cuts of games like say you
could have a cut that has less story or
a cut that has more story rather than
just a difficulty option and yeah the
new Monkey Island actually kind of did
it
um which is really cool
I have had this conversation a bunch
recently and was like let me ask Mike
why do you think nobody has has uh
at this rate and it's surely it can't be
ideas surely someone's thought of this
for me put in a rewind function for
cutscenes if you're missing something
you get a phone call somebody says
something why can we not pause and
Rewind a cutscene in a video game
oh there's so much so many reasons it
just seems like such a no-brainer Mike
just just you just do it yeah let's do
it
so
it so so it depends so it's boring
answer maybe really depends is there is
the genuine I mean yeah every game runs
differently but like yeah none of them
have done it
right so there's a few reasons I would
say
I'll roll through them and it to be it
to be fair a lot of them are similar
he's a waste it's similar to um why is
there why do you not why can you not
skip cutscenes or pause cut scenes yeah
the same thing yeah
yeah so the first question the first
answer and I think probably this is more
frequently true than either of us would
like to admit [ __ ] grave director
like like [ __ ] you you can't skip my
story you can't skip my cutscenes you
know this is my vision how dare you and
I've been I remember
early in my career before I was making
my own stuff
um I remember working on a project we
cut scenes where the entire team did a
basically like all of a signed a letter
to the director of that game
begging this person to let us to put a
skip button on the cutscenes because
we're like this game is objectively
worse because of our bad cutscenes and
we as a team wow would like to allow
people to skip it oh wow I imagine that
would mortify a director
I mean a self-aware director sure
um but uh but yeah so that was so so
I've been on and I think that's
something that again players I think
sometimes don't realize is that those
conversations happen internally as well
like if if the community is saying
something is wrong I promise you 100
people within the team at some point
someone on the team also didn't like it
someone didn't like it someone probably
got in trouble for moaning about it so
there's that so that's the first reason
is people don't want their Vision
touched and I I I don't like that as an
explanation but I can I can it
definitely happens
the next one is
um is often the case is rewinds uh uh
cutscenes are hiding loading so for
example like I think this has been the
case forever with like the um the Call
of Duty games so Call of Duty when a
cutscene's playing it's a video and
underneath that video is a loading bar
that's invisible to you you can't see
and it's literally like gonna take
pre this I think this generation of
consoles obviously loading a lot faster
but previous generation consoles like
Call of Duty levels were taking like
minutes to load you just didn't notice
as a player because there was a cutscene
playing over the top of it so if you
allow someone to mess with that video
um
memory that's needed well like the
rewinds right well first of all you want
to see a loading bar because if we give
you a rewind we have to give you a fast
forward so if you skip through a cut
scene or you you get that loan bar and
that's often the cases you can skip a
cut scene on like a Call of Duty and
you'll see the loading bar but yes with
rewinds so there is a there's
proprietary Tech that exists I think uh
bink's probably the logo ever unseen at
the start of a bunch of games with video
um basically how to make video stream on
a console it's easier now because the
technology is stronger but like has
always been like a tricky one of how do
you make video streamer high quality as
you say with like as lower memory input
as possible a memory uh Footprints as
possible because you're you're doing all
this other stuff behind the scenes
um and just kind of keeping in sync and
doing all of its things video is tricky
because most computer game code isn't
designed to work on an absolutely
reliable uh Rhythm it's built to happen
as fast as possible before you render
the frame so there's a hole so making
video and date and games interact is is
always like a point of like weird
technological trickiness and there's a
lot of middleware now that kind of deals
with that for most developers so it's
fine but that could be part of it the
more control we give you overplay back
of that video it causes some weird
issues
so that's part that's that's the next
one the one that I think is most
interesting is well not necessarily most
interesting but like I think is often
the case is cut scenes that are rendered
in engine are doing so much trickery all
the time that making stuff able to be
cleanly rewound is tricky so particle
effects in video games for example are
often uh not designed to go backwards
particle effects uh don't have causality
in the way that you'd expect for or that
you'd see in like a video a particle
doesn't exist until it's spawned and it
goes through its life cycle and plays
and plays out and then is despawned and
deleted forever and not nothing about
that path that particle took is is saved
you can use kind of random seeds in
order to make them predictable but
whenever you've seen a game as a
mechanic have rewind in it it's so much
more complicated than people realize to
make that work rewind because because
everything in a game is designed to roll
forward going backwards is tricky even
if it's a cutscene which
theory is more akin to a video
if it's playing back in 3D then it's
basically in the way most of this is sub
it's still using all those video game
texts so you would still be using
particle systems like a game you'd still
be rendering
um but yeah most video games I mean to
even funnier video games through a bunch
of Tricks right like to function at all
a bunch of shits hidden in a bunch of
places to make anything functional
whatsoever anything new you want to do
requires work yeah but another good
example is like with um animation so a
lot of the time and every game's
different in this regard but with
animation in games
um obviously frame rate is variable so
you don't know if the game's gonna be
running at 60 FPS 30 FPS 20 FPS if
you're making a PC game and someone runs
it on a bad PC or in the future 120
frames a second when ps6 allows you to
play backwards compatible but
everything's up to 120 frames a second
like nobody knows we don't know what the
situation is going to be so most so good
games and most modern games are frame
rate independent in the sense that like
you can play them at different frame
rates and it will basically play the
same if you go back and play a lot of
old games on emulators like the car will
move 10 times as fast because it was
never meant to be played right I had a
reasonable frame rate
um with that in mind animation for
example often in games isn't actually
playing like 30 FPS like frame by frame
by frame by frame by frame because it
has to look smooth over say 60 frames a
second it might be automatically kind of
tweening between those frames otherwise
you'd get kind of that that's that
Spider-Man animation effect where things
are out of sync with the frame rates so
even animation is faking Blends on a
frame by frame basis to look smooth to
you so if you pause an animation mid
flow and Rewind it
you've got to then predict where you
were on that smoothing so that you can
kind of cycle back none of these
problems are impossible to solve and
there are games obviously they've done
rewinding it's a matter of if it's worth
it it takes exactly and when you're
making a video game and you're up
against the deadline and you've got a
list of 1000 jobs you've got to do
adding a rewind feature to the cutscene
is never going to get a priority
placement I'm sure I've said this before
but I think um I didn't realize until
working in AAA that
so much of Game Dev is
um
is is this is this worth
the cost
like so much of it is like you can have
this idea but is it can we weigh up if
we have that thing then we probably
can't have this thing and that's not
stuff that happens at the end that's
stuff that happens the whole way through
of like well yeah you can do that but if
you do that then we can't have that
um because it's finite and it's so
finite and I think that like there's so
many things and you'll see people on the
internet like oh it would have been cool
if you did this why didn't you do this
why isn't this boss bigger you're like
okay for every time you have to make
that boss bigger we have to cut a puddle
yeah
and honestly the fact that you that it's
your belief that those decisions are
made throughout the course of
development immediately tells me that
Santa Monica is a well-run studio
because I've got a lot of game studios a
lot of game CEOs don't make those
decisions until towards the end and
that's why crunch happens is because the
scope just gets out of hand and some
I've I've definitely I've had
conversations with developers where
they're like why would you you don't
know what game you're making for three
quarters of development it's like you
better because you're gonna you're gonna
really really hurt people towards the
end if you've not made those decisions
um but yeah no it's it's it is always a
trade-off it is always a decision-making
process and those decisions can be made
for lots of different reasons what's
interesting and I remember reading
someone say this that that's kind of
video game what what the difference
between like a junior member of the
games industry and like a senior
experienced person is is largely their
ability to predict those kind of
trade-offs
um and and to know like okay that's that
thing is gonna cost us a lot yeah XYZ
the amount of games that we wanted a
populated town like just in general like
but what if there were people in it
you're like do you know how hard that is
yeah and yeah and it's always it's
always those those things what's cool is
you get to a level and I'm not I don't
think I'm at this level but when you
meet people and I bet there's a lot of
people you work with who are like the
20-year veteran
that person is often amazing at knowing
oh this is going to be so expensive but
here's how we can do it you know what I
mean like in finding that Solution
that's where genuinely awesome things
come from
um and the other thing is you know the
technology advances the industry
experience Advanced is something that is
really difficult to do now won't be in a
few years yeah you know we're going
through we're going through that right
now with
a lot of stuff on the visual side thanks
to Unreal Engine 5 like the
conversations that are happening around
like stuff that was inaccessible to
developers only you know a few years ago
is suddenly like no we can actually talk
about that now that's interesting
um and it's happening on a million
fronts with all the engines and all the
hardware so it's it's always you're
always learning and kind of figuring out
where those lines are but yeah
if we can make a character float can
they just float they can't fly because
that's a whole new mechanic but if they
float we don't have to animate their
legs can we just yeah we want to have a
character can we just make them float
like it's like an invisible Escape
because then they can just play their
eyes and you don't have to worry about
anything
everything's so much here very simple
there's a conversation I had today yeah
that's yeah 100 it's become a running
joke and like anything that's got four
legs you're like do we need that thing
with four legs and then Ragnarok is very
much a wolf game and I mean the the
amount of time that it took to make that
um the dog sled uh was the wolf sled I
guess was extremely difficult like
that's okay but there will have been a
conversation where someone was like
because I bet you there's other wolves
and four-legged animals all over that
game right yeah because there's one
there's multiple because you've got the
system like that's the thing and that's
the trade-off and that's the genius of
like the really experienced skill yeah
we've got this one yes
one part of the game where you do have
like I think it's really funny it's like
a bunch of wolves just keep showing up
um and I would say that that is
literally that they were like well we've
already [ __ ] spent all that time
making the goddamn wolves walk
um and that was also like a pretty late
thing to happen to for a really long
time throughout the the older builds the
Wolves were basically just skating um
because animating them was really hard
and even their facial capture there were
a lot of like scenes where a wolf is
supposed to do something like sweet or
cute that just got the image of
someone's sticking little balls on the
face of a dog
facial capture a lot of wolves
and yeah we so we just have a bunch of
wolves because making anything with the
amount of times that I heard the word
quadruped
just keep getting notifications on this
PC did you know Jeremy D is now playing
Uno everyone's gonna see the the capture
because it's I haven't turned it off
um oh is it just coming off it keeps
coming up on the on the podcast The Game
Pass and now it's Jeremy playing Uno
um but yeah it's definitely stuff like
that that I just never considered and
again I'm sure we said it on the show
before but everything that you've you
think why didn't this game do this
someone at the studio also thought
and it wasn't possible for any Myriad of
reasons it is the conversation can shift
like this is what's really interesting
to me on the accessibility stuff is
everything every single accessibility
feature that you know Sony games are
massively known for now but but even
like the the kind of the smaller subset
of that that Indie Games often do like
all of that stuff
was and is a difficult job like it's
something that takes away time forever
because everything is takes a long time
it's so interesting watching that
conversation because of the people
who've evangelized that stuff because
the people who've kind of spoken up on
it and because honestly the pressure
that's been applied to especially to AAA
Studios the building Awards that's the
whole thing exactly was just to make
people go we should probably do that and
yeah
without Awards
what I'm saying
is now you have to start the room the
reap the best rewind in cutscenes Awards
well put a category in yeah I guess it's
like extra
no we could do it I was gonna say extra
tell for us with an uncut camera but it
could still it could could in theory be
done but you're right is it a priority
is is probably the biggest thing and um
it just seems like it would be [ __ ]
great because even I like playing
through something I will have to I'll
miss a cutscene and I'll miss context
all the time and it just seems like
something to be very helpful but you
also have to prioritize like a people
playing it for the cutscenes how many
people are what game is it like
what would be relatively why imagine
would be relatively easy would be
um like a cutscene replayer because
there's definitely games to have done
that like with metal gear I remember the
Amelia side too I think and you could
literally like swap out the character
models which is a fun gimmick but like
those kind of replays because save and
load is tricky as well right so the way
that I currently do it if I miss
something in a cutscene that um on the
Xbox you say Xbox record that or at
least if you had connect I don't even
know if it does it anymore but you can
save the last like 15 30 seconds on Xbox
One
well it yeah the I don't even really
know how that works to be honest because
I don't understand it must just be
saving it must be constantly recording
and then just delete deleting it because
like if you get a trophy on Playstation
generally you will have a replay of when
you got the trophy
um which is like such a cool feature so
I would usually do that if I missed
something I'll pause and I'll I'll check
the last 30 seconds or whatever which is
definitely an option but it doesn't work
on PC because PCS don't function that
way and
you don't have that much control over
how much time you're trying to go back
the whole cutscene how long is the
cutscene whatever so it is a good
alternative that it just yeah must be
constantly recording and deleting
you know another factor is is so save
load is tricky like like again games are
designed to be played in order so if you
want it if you so it's quite hard to add
like if you wanted to take a game and go
oh I just want to go back like two
levels earlier and start from there
that's actually a tricky thing to kind
of figure out as it is depending on how
complicated your game is like that can
be in itself tricky just because
Europe because save save data is is not
designed to be used that way save data
you can you can do it but like it can
it's a tricky thing to add later
potentially which is what I was going to
say is is
with a lot of things in game development
the later you leave them in the process
the harder they then are to do so like
localization for example we as a studio
we localize from like the first
prototype just because it's such a
nightmare to add localization to a game
right at the end
um similar with like uh UI scaling so
you know going back to the accessibility
thing like it's something we've we've
definitely got dinned for in previous
games that our text was too small so we
we started doing UI scaling but like
again like day one from day one all of
our games we are now or at least the
ones I'm directing are like UI scaling
from from the start you do these things
early it's much easier cut scenes
because of the nature of Productions cut
scenes are often the last thing you do
because cutscenes are dependent on Arts
from every other thing in the game being
close to Final in order to kind of
finally set them up
um all they're using as they yeah you're
using assets everywhere you don't do the
cut scenes till the end because they're
sometimes they're done by like an
Outsourcing company there's lots of
reasons that cutscenes are you usually
one of the last things you do so at that
point adding any functionality is quite
tricky so if someone
was doing the cut scenes and went I'd be
really nice if there's a rewind button
chances are you're already past the beta
and no one wants to add major features
yeah so that could also be a factor that
it's kind of cutscenes are often like an
afterthought from like a production
pipeline point of view you know yeah you
have to prioritize the video game Parts
first and um like accessible which is
reasonable and there's a gamer that's
what I like but yeah the accessibility
stuff
um at Santa Monica Studio is being
worked on constantly which is awesome so
it was basically constantly being worked
on in tandem with every other part of
the game so that you know whenever we
had a new build they would just have the
new accessibility options in the build
constantly
um there's a team of it's the best way
to do that kind of feature yeah um
headed by Mila who's uh I should look up
her actual title I think she's like UI
lead but also um Sam shaffel who came
from Naughty Dog and then worked at
Santa Monica Studio uh both of them were
like so so wonderful it's um Mia pavlin
is lead ux designer and she's the one
who's done most of like the interviews
regarding a lot of the accessibility
stuff which again is awesome but there
are some producers who are really
passionate about it as well which is
super important
um
but it was basically constant like
it wasn't an afterthought it wasn't a
maybe somebody thought of this let's try
and throw that in it was literally just
the two things in tandem at all times
which is why it ended up yeah the way
that it is it's awesome it's the only
way to it's what it what it's what makes
it really hard when you launch a game
and definitely like we launched a couple
of games while the accessibility
conversation was just starting up and I
remember getting like valid criticism of
our games going oh well this this isn't
very good for these kind of players
um and the heartbreaking thing is at
that point like changing that fixing
that would be such a massive chunk of
work that we just wouldn't we wouldn't
be able to do it and especially scaled
up to AAA that would be even impossible
more impossible so yeah doing it from
day one that's the best way anything
like that is you know much easier if you
do it with immediately kind of from the
start yeah and I I don't think that
I think people who need certain
accessibility options should always
speak up about them and then it's it's
not such an order but to be clear to the
audience like definitely speak up yeah
you should always speak up about it
um because part of the problem with
accessibility is how would you know
somebody needs something it's a very
difficult thing to actually put a lot of
research into because it's also an
impossible problem to fix there will
never be a game that is 100 accessible
it is not possible because you don't
know the global needs right you can make
things as accessible as possible and
Cater 2 has many different kinds of
disabilities as possible but if you
don't know that somebody has the need
how would you know to make it um so it's
it's a thing where I don't fault people
for not having accessible games I've
been very disappointed in things for not
having accessibility options
um like I recently had a stream that was
a sponsored stream but I couldn't play
the game because I was like this
requires rapid button presses and that's
a thing that I can't do and I've spoken
about my issues with that um so I was
like I would have loved to have but I
literally can't play a game uh it's just
too painful and requires me to like ice
my wrists and I had a lot of trouble
with the original Spider-Man and um that
I can play now and like Miles Morales I
was like oh this hurts a lot
um and I can only play it for about 15
minutes but they do have accessibility
options that really help get rid of like
rapid button tapping which is always my
problem so it's like it's something that
yes you have to think about from the
start but it's also something that I
don't I never expect anybody to
have all the answers or be perfect I
just expect them to be open to it I
think is the thing is like you just at
least let people
suggest and want to hear that feedback
unless you're a jerk are you a big old
jerk then that it is also possible
um yeah
yeah because you could never know
never know what all of the accessibility
needs are that's why you need
consultants and you need a bunch of
people to help and you can play God of
War Ragnarok with one hand and a big
part of that was that Sam shaffel who
was working on the accessibility team I
believe he was like full-time on that
team
um only has one hand so he was our play
test for that you you play the game with
one hand the sample played the game with
one hand that's it's [ __ ] awesome the
fact that you can do that is so so cool
but it still requires the that specific
uh need to
not need that specific disability like
someone to actually test it with that
specific disability which is not
accessible to all studios in the world
Cinema Studio it's a lot easier for us
and naughty dogs but it's such an
exciting area of design as well like I
think this is it like I like the the the
kind of the ux challenges of just like
doing a con like doing anyone who's ever
tried to like you know take a controller
and work out control scheme knows how
impossibly difficult yeah it is to work
out just a control scheme assuming there
are two hands on the controller like the
idea of taking something as complex as
God of War and making it work uh 100 and
presumably with either hand right that's
that's going to be part of it too I I'm
Amazed by that that's that's that's
phenomenally cool and that's like yeah
as a as a designer the opportunity there
to kind of come up with new stuff and
try new stuff that's just I think we're
gonna see I've said the same thing about
like uh although narrative design is
further along but we're definitely one
of the coolest thing about things about
games is that we are constantly
inventing new jobs and new kind of
people in the process I came into the
industry like as one of the first kind
of generation of game designers like it
was there wasn't really the concept of
game design three or four years before I
started my career interesting and now
it's at Sony the writers are on the
design team which I think makes sense
that's right because um I've said this
before on the show but I feel more
confident in seeing it now
I imagine this is the case that a lot of
AAA Studios like at least the people who
work full time
a lot of my job is narrative design to
the extent that while our narrative
designers do do something different
um I'm effectively just a different
facet of narrative design and I think
again that's why I'm on the design team
there isn't a writing Team all of the
writers are on design
10 years ago you would have been a
contractor given two months exactly and
that yes those are people who are just
more just right they're like gameplay
says hey we need you to write this and
you're right that was it like 10 years
ago like when I came into industry that
was I remember I remember the writer
would come in for a couple of days sit
with a team play the game go oh I see
what kind of game this is and then they
go off and write us like yeah and that's
my point is that's what's exciting about
the games industry is now we have this
amazing field now of narrative design
and writing and as you say kind of it
Blends it becomes part of the process
that's really cool I think the same is
gonna come with this kind of
accessibility approach especially as the
audience is aging especially for those
reasons like I think there's just it's
just
anymore my eyesight deteriorated I think
a lot of it happened during the pandemic
and I have to wear my glasses and I
can't I can't or I just can't see or I'm
like doing this at the TV and uh the
things that I didn't need in God of War
2018 that are really helpful in Ragnarok
um we have a lot of text options and
they're really cool but one of them is
like a blurred box behind text and it
helps so much and I think that's a part
of accessibility that a lot of people
aren't willing to accept that I like
I've been on a bunch of Ritz about is
that accessibility isn't just for people
who are born with disabilities it's also
for you as you get older you stupid [ __ ]
I think it's like okay I came off a
motorbike and I couldn't use my hands
there are certain games I could still
play just a little bit
um I I you know I got tendonitis in my
wrist that's why I can't do any
uh rapid presses and that's how I got so
involved in accessibility in the first
place or why I cared so much as there
are games that I can't play because I
played too many video games and I [ __ ]
my thumbs up
Um this can happen to all of you like
accessibility options
it's true your body will fall apart it
will be harder to play video games so
accessibility
you're temporarily able yeah yeah it's
and then situational disabilities are a
big one it's like you're getting an
accident you can't play video games
anymore you lose a hand you can't play
video games anymore that can happen
um the we're all we're all gonna need
these tools and I think that's that's
what's interesting to me situations that
I've been trying to talk about more
recently because yeah people like have
it in their head that accessibility is
is just for a certain kind of person but
it's it's for everybody and situational
disability is like say you have a puppy
um and the puppy goes to tear up your
couch the game doesn't have a pause menu
so you can't pause so you're always the
boss fight uh that is a situational
disability you are unable to continue to
play through that because of the
situation that you're in and you are
disabled from doing that um so it's I
don't know I just feel like we should
reframe accessibility because people
have a weird negative association with
that word I don't think it should have a
negative connotation it's an awesome
thing but it's really just customization
and customization that will support you
under any circumstance in any
situational disability for anything that
you can't do for any reason uh whether
it's an injury whether it's you have a
baby any relatable human thing that you
are guaranteed to go through these
customization options can make sure that
you can still play video games
it's a win-win that's all I'm saying I
just there's it's weird the things
people choose to be territorial about
it's like Star Trek fans complaining I
saw Star Trek found I'm a big Star Trek
nerd I saw Star Trek fans complaining oh
they're just trying to get 20 year olds
into Star Trek it's like what are you
what's wrong with that you'll get more
Star Trek for the next 30 Years what are
you talking about like it's just it's
yeah I've never understood gatekeeping
it's so strange like why would you not
want more people to like the thing you
like I don't I guess that it does make
sense it's it's insecurity right it's
just people who feel special that's
that's what I saw a really interesting I
don't I it's it's a lot it's a bit pop
psychology but I it was it was an
interesting concept was the idea that
the the kind of Our Generations are
um because we're having children slower
we're owning property slower because
we're just not basically
gaining ownership of things at the young
age the previous generations did that
people are placing much more that kind
of
um that kind of uh uh materialistic or
ownership kind of love that or the idea
of like expressing yourself by the
things you own is being passed not on is
being passed on to Media rather than
onto things so it's not that you're
house proud you're uh you know DC proud
you know like it's like you you put
those emotions for capitalism there
huge win for the system geez I don't
know that's I mean that definitely
sounds like some pop psychology [ __ ]
on some level but there's something to
that I think the law
you need to stop naming things that I
should have happened
at least
um do you know what it was it was Brave
New World was on the reading list at
school which is why I didn't read no no
easy way it was on the reading list at
school
I remember breaking you well yeah it was
one of the books we were meant to read
at school what the [ __ ]
20s I'm
I'm Ling uh some colleagues that I was
reading it and I was like I I texted
someone on my team it was like why
didn't you tell me who this was going to
happen it has some really [ __ ] up
stuff in it but uh one Concept in it
that the thing that I'm specifically
referring to being [ __ ] up is
the eroticism of children
explicitly in the first few pages
um and torturing babies happens in the
first 10 pages uh in a way that's like
oh my god um I understand why it's all
there it's painting a picture like it
has purpose it's not like indulgent in a
gross way but like children are punished
if they don't like
the engage in erotic play uh Wild
but there's this theme in it that uh
every time it comes up I just find so
interesting that is basically
um new sports are invented and they are
only allowed to be played or to be
passed on or like to to flourish if they
require you to buy more things than the
last sport
so you can't just have soccer anymore
because that only requires a ball and
some goals it has to also require like
gear and a paddle and like you just have
to every new sport must require you to
consume more things than the last sport
so they saw Warhammer coming is what
you're saying very much
and you so you just have to keep like
it's a it's a culture that's based on
consumption and that you need to consume
and that that is an accepted part of
society is like you must consume at all
times keep consuming we must make more
things for people to consume and part of
that that kind of works in this world
which is not a world that anybody is
suggesting is good it's an extremely
negative book but
um like dystopia effectively it's it's
not they're not trying to say it's a
good thing is so what you're saying is a
Billionaire's gonna try and reproduce it
the next couple of years then yeah fair
enough you could see it happening cat
snow blind they really didn't get
cyberpunk position
sorry Karma yeah it's everyone else in
society is also in support of of the
consumption and then the other theme of
it that is very prevalent is I guess
everybody's on drugs to make them happy
which also seems like a part of constant
consumption is that your needs will
never feel fulfilled I guess they're all
bred to
um be in certain costs that make them
want certain things and be opposed to
certain things so they all operate the
same way and
monogamy is extremely frowned upon I
think it's even illegal so the concept
is everybody must belong to everybody
else
um so it's just yet the
the consumerism stuff is pretty on point
and I think that it's a thing that's
even hard to turn off just for everybody
in general is like to
to stop
consuming [ __ ] but to replace that
consumption
um with like you know it took me ages to
stop buying statues all the time was
like I just have to stop doing this I
keep feeling like it fulfills me and I
have to stop doing it because it does
fulfill me and that's the problematic
part it's like but it's nice art
um but I have to stop doing it but
it's so snowy it's so pretty um yeah
replacing the buying a house and having
stability and having a car or whatever
with like the amount of
media that you consume the amount of
subscriptions that you have the amount
of films that you get a sense of
ownership over that and you see that as
well manifesting like how angry people
get like changes to Media they like or
more inclusive Media or whatever that's
interesting it's
I know they uh I think I might have even
said this on the show before but um I
was also reading very civilly easily
discredited thing that I've not thought
that hard about but the idea that people
or I was reading this or somebody told
it to me I could keep having that I
don't even know that people
um
uh less likely to be nostalgic for
things that happened and more likely to
be nostalgic for products now
so when we talk about Nostalgia that's
media we talk about the movies we
watched I think about Pokemon I think
about even Harry Potter uh that's the
thing that I grew up reading that my
Nostalgia is tied to Brands a lot more
often than it's tied to activities which
is almost like a friend or a first kiss
or a kind of the standard what like when
you're like oh I'm so nostalgic for this
my head goes Nintendo 64. like straight
away Nintendo 64 is the first thing that
comes in my head and and sure it's the
Nintendo 64 because I was playing Mario
Party with a group of friends or
whatever but it's still Nintendo 64. but
it's the product and the recognizable
face yeah again the way we talk about
80s movies right it's like people are
nostalgic for 80s movies you see the
poster you hear the music you get
nostalgic from media rather than
experiences
it is nice one one reassuring thing and
I can't remember which Youtuber did this
in a video recently I can't remember who
I was watching but basically someone
pointed out this whole thing that often
does the rounds where you'll see like
people recognize
um cartoon character not associated with
the current partner of mine more than
they recognize Jesus right you'll see
that kind of do the rounds as like and
people will say oh this is you know
corporations are taking over and uh you
know capitalism is the new is the new
religion all this stuff and someone I
was watching made the point that um a
similar thing happened in the 20s like
there was in the 20s there was a similar
survey and it was like I think it was
like a a cartoon character of a cereal
box that's completely lost to history
but like at the time was just like the
most iconic brand and exactly the same
stats of like more more kids know this
cereal brand icon than they know you
know Father Christmas or Jesus or
whatever and so it doesn't I think one
of the reasons
one of one of the reasons that sci-fi
feels prophetic is because it does come
to pass like sometimes like the things
you've seen that in something like Brave
New World can I come to fruition but I
think also it feels prophetic because
people are people and like you're in a
world now that's inspiring those same uh
connotations and fears and existential
crises as was Brave New World like the
70s
um something like that pretty close to
1984. let me check I mean they were
written but because these men have
opinions publication date my guy 1932.
no way that's an old ass book
that's wild because even though I'd not
read it I I knew of what was in it and
stuff like that sounds really that's way
ahead of its time okay I'm just saying
this on a podcast to somebody else sorry
I'll let you finish your story first
it's an aside go ahead
I'm just gonna say people are people
like like he was reacting to exactly the
same world on a human level as we are
like things feel it's inhuman nature to
feel like things are always getting
worse no they're not mainly because of
nostalgia they're not at all because of
how you felt yeah I asked my Dad
recently I was like what was it like to
actually grow up in the 80s like what
was that like and he was like oh it's
really free we weren't worried about
anything we weren't worried about crying
and I was like you know crime rate's
gone down since then and he was like
that can't be true and so I read him
stats because that's the [ __ ] that I
am it's like someone's like I'll just be
like let me go to statistics it must be
insufferable to most people who love me
but
um and he was like I can't believe that
and I was like yeah you just know about
more of it now we crime rates are
extremely low right now
um it's and it's a really fun one to
tell Boomer parents especially if
they're like the world's gonna do [ __ ]
it hasn't your perception of it has
changed but we haven't defensive Boomer
parents they're being piped that mess
all the media that's targeted yeah and
like unless you go in and tell tell them
actually crime rates I think it's
virtually globally have decreased since
the 90s and there's also no statistical
reason why
um there isn't any actually verified
like because I was looking into it when
I had this conversation there's no
actually like completely verified
um indication of why the decline seemed
to happen pretty much globally at the
same time and my guess was that it's
surveillance is it the the there was one
Theory that's interesting go ahead birth
control
birth control plus 20 years
interesting because if you have less
unwanted children
you have less criminals that's I don't
know if that's true but that's the
theory Theory less people in poverty but
I don't know that poverty rates have
decreased
at the same rate yeah I've heard I've
heard the theory that
um interesting yeah the basically the
less unwanted children the less criminal
I mean that because it makes sense a lot
of yeah I feel I feel like surveillance
surely like you can pull out a camera so
it's also possible yeah well you say
that but like I think there's a lot of
data because the UK is one of the most
like surveilled countries in the world
like in terms of like it's scary to
remember like when Americans come over
here they freak out PCC UB cameras there
are but I think there's there's
compelling data that doesn't really have
a massive effect on crime rates really I
would have thought that the more
surveilled areas don't get him more
interesting yeah I mean Australia's Got
a lot of CCTV as well I had a guy I had
to report to the cops who wants to do
something illegal in
Brisbane and in order to find him they
followed my route so they found me
coming off the train and then because I
was like well I walked here and he was
here when he did this and so they
followed me through the city until they
found where I would have gotten there
and they were like well I was like he
came from the other direction so then
they used the cameras like minutes
before to find him and that's how they
found him and charged him which is nuts
it was like you just followed where I
was figured out exactly what time I got
there and then followed him in the other
direction from there it was crazy it was
like CCT not so bad not so bad yeah it
was a dude who uh I was um maybe 14
maybe I was older than that one and he
came up to me and offered me
um money to buy the underwear that I was
wearing
and so I immediately just I knew that
was a police station around the corner
so I was like I'm gonna tell the cops
about this one that's
that was underage and that was very
uncomfortable and uh let's just report
that one straight away and it turned out
that he had done it to like maybe 10
people uh that had had reported it and
they were all underage
that's both incredibly impressive the
14U did that but also completely
unsurprising given a lot of the adult
that I know that you would absolutely be
someone who went no no and solved it
right that's one thing that I think
about that experience you probably
helped some kids you probably help some
other girls my intention was to stop him
from doing it again but the thing that I
think about the exact reaction is
obviously I was very uncomfortable is
that I said no sorry
why did I apologize and I've gotten that
I never left my head that I said no I'm
sorry
um and I think I even said have a good
day
why did I say something says a lot
doesn't it about what the expectations
were on you and and how you somebody
being intimidated yeah it's like well I
don't want to increase the threat or
whatever
um but yeah that's stuck in my head for
sure but that said I could I could go on
attention about the worst thing I saw as
a child but I also reported the police
but uh that my parents reported that one
but well we'll say that for another day
it's uh it's been something
um Austin and Troy are in Venice
together which is why they aren't here
the time Zone's a bit weird and
Austin said sorry our night is running
long and he just sent me this like
beautiful picture of I don't know what
this is but
I know some Italian [ __ ] it looks
picture beautiful
um I could pick up where I left off for
the audience we'll do the whole thing
um yeah
um they loved this last time it was
great yeah you want to keep reading he
makes this a patreon thing and I was
like I need to call someone at Disney
and work out if I could the other right
it's very good do a do a full thing uh
well I'm a lot of pissed but I'm a video
getting ready that is Mike Bethel he is
a video game director this is playwatch
listen and we will hopefully see you
next week it's game awards so it's gonna
be pretty chaotic but uh we'll try hi
everyone
[Music]
[Music]
foreign